foreign
Natasha how are you
hi I'm good and you guys better than we
deserve what's up in your world well
um my word has been upside down for the
last seven years
um we me and my husband have a husband
being very good managing money
I believe we both make good money my
husband works in the film industry and
we end up moving to Atlanta so he had
like a stable job here in income and I
am a teacher so we make around eighty
thousand dollars and sometimes it could
be all the way to a hundred dollars
yearly but it has been a roller coaster
for us to be on the same page and
finally we found your program and we're
trying to make the right choices
this next two months we're gonna be like
negative zero we're just gonna pay all
our you know regular utilities and our
payments are pretty high so we're trying
to figure it out right now if we have to
get rid of one of our cars even though
our cars don't pay as much we have one
car is 560 a month the other is 400 a
month uh monthly
but we just don't know where to start
right now we're I'm I'm gonna do like a
garage sale to make the thousand dollars
to start for a savings we have zero
savings
we're just a mess and we need to know
how can we start something
are you guys doing a budget
well that's the first thing we started
um but right now the budget is ideally
but we have so much things that are like
overdue payments that you know if we're
not gonna even have enough money for the
bot yet we're gonna have to catch up the
next two months just doing payments and
just doing payment well I think that
you're a little bit confused about how
the budget is working so what you're
going to do so what do you bring home
every month around four thousand dollars
um I bring
2800 and my husband brings six thousand
oh six thousand oh okay great so you're
going to plug that into your budget uh
what how do you do your budget now is it
a spreadsheet what are you using to
create your budget every month
I just have a it's not really a
spreadsheet it's just you know a chart
that I created and it's we have a
thousand dollars for a hundred dollars
that's income okay eight thousand four
hundred and or our goal is eight
thousand eight um 180. okay well let's
start with what your outgo actually is
so you're gonna start with the 8400 and
you're just gonna go down the line and
you're gonna spend all of that money so
you're gonna start with your expenses
and go through making sure that you're
making minimum payments on everything
not just your you know the expenses that
you do every month like groceries and
things like that but also your debt
and just to keep everything current I
know that you said that you're behind on
some stuff but start out by making
minimum payments
and once you've done that I think you're
going to find that there are things that
you're spending money on that you don't
actually need to spend money on because
you guys have a great income what kind
of uh what kind of debt do you have on
well we have the two car loans and car
number one that you owe 400 a month on
it what's the balance on it
21 that's 160 what's the balance on it
no that was a
405.60 so one the 560 is 25
000 and the 400 is 12 000. okay all
right and what are your other debts
the student loans how much around twenty
thousand dollars
okay what else
we also have um medical bills and there
are already affected our credit scores
and how much I don't I don't know the
number for that I think it's a roughly
around fifteen thousand dollars and
you're paying monthly on these
we're not okay so you're not paying
anything on that you're not paying
anything on that at all okay what else
um well
that's it like what's your house
we paid we don't own we rent what's your
rent
2000 a month 2 000 a month okay yeah all
right what are you behind on
right now we're on three months of the
car and we also laid one month on rent
okay so what that tells me is is that
you all are out of control on your
spending
because you have enough to pay these
bills I don't even know where you're
getting to 8 400 I can't get there
you're not paying anything on these
medical you got 2 000 plus you got food
lights and water and then you got a
thousand sixty and or no you got 916
credit card debt or in car payments
student loans on hold with Biden
yeah you're not paying anything on it
you're not working a budget I think
you're just guessing at the numbers
every month and if you're not on a
budget you guys are spending like crazy
and then you're not prioritizing the
things
this is what has been happening like I
tried to for us to speak upon a budget
who's the spender you or him
I think both I think we're both very bad
spending and why does it say on my
screen you're considering a divorce
yeah why does it say on my screen you're
considering a divorce
you haven't brought that up in our
conversation
I did
um sometimes the Escape that I feel I
have from the situation
oh you know that would be if it's his
fault
but you didn't just now say it was his
fault you said it was both your fault
but it's hard to for both of us to be on
the same page it's just hard like for
now I I explain him that we need to like
close our personal accounts and one of
the things that you guys recommend is
for those who have want to count
together and he's like okay we can open
one account but we will still keep
temporary Accounts at the same time I
feel he doesn't try separate accounts
aren't your problem
your problem as you spin like you're in
Congress
somewhere between the two of you
I'm sorry what do you say last I said
you spend out of control no number of
accounts will stop that
having a singular account's not going to
fix that getting rid of him is not going
to fix it if you're the problem
so what we've got to do is you guys are
going to have to lay out a game plan
that the two of you agree to and
um you guys are getting ready to head
into bankruptcy because you're going to
get evicted and repoed you're not but
one car payment of boy from getting into
repo land and you're about half a
mortgage or half of the rent payment
from being evicted if you're my tenant
because I don't fool around people not
paying their rent
so uh you guys got to get this stuff
together uh we didn't have time to do a
full counseling session for Co for money
on the air let me help you guys if
you're out there facing that because I
feel like we didn't address the key
issue that would be a great learning for
everyone else
if you are behind
on your payments
behind on your bills how do you do a
budget
okay
well the first thing you do is you have
to Force rank
prioritize
you have to prioritize your dollars and
that means we're going to take care of
what we used to learn and they no longer
teach it in the eighth grade called
Civics the difference in necessities and
luxuries
98 of what everybody spends money on in
America is a freaking luxury
so let me help you with what an actual
necessity is
food
there's one no eating out is not a
necessity
some of you people all you know how to
make is reservations and you got to work
on that okay so food at home cheap that
you bought at the grocery store with a
coupon food is a necessity
utilities lights and water so you have
heat
and cool utilities is number two cable
is not a utility cable is not a utility
thank you Hulu is not on your list oh
Netflix is not a necessity Tiger King
let me help you okay I just had to put
that out there just helping you with
your little increase there to 12.95
uh okay I've got it all but I'm not
broke okay so I got Hulu and Netflix so
I'll just give them a little ad there
but they're not a necessity
you can live without them
promise you
now once you've gotten food and
utilities were belly's full and we're
warm
number three is shelter
so you take care of your place to live
so you're not homeless you pay your rent
now almost everyone can scratch around
and make enough money to buy their food
keep their electricity current if
they're first
second and third and keep your rent paid
right the only way you get behind on
rent which our last caller was is if you
are completely discombobulated screwed
up and you're spending crazy money on
something else
you'd have to be it's the only way
because otherwise you go okay I'm gonna
go out to eat but I'm gonna get evicted
that's called
insanity
I mean stupid right yeah you know we're
going on this trip but we're gonna get
evicted well you that that's I mean what
are your parents cousins really I mean
seriously no one does that but people do
it all the time because when we get all
stressed out we don't Force rank
priorities and if you'll just get real
calm cool and collected and go we're
gonna eat before we do anything not eat
out we're going to pay the utilities not
cable before we do anything we're going
to pay rent and when you do those three
things you got a lot of money most of
you left over after those three things
then the next one is transportation yeah
now that this is the one that gets
people Dave no well they had 960 dollars
in car payments they did so we're going
to fix their transportation problem
because we're going to sell that crap
tomorrow okay if you can't pay the car
payment hello there's a signal here God
is saying sell the car
it wasn't even Dave God said it and you
know how I know he said that the
blessings of the Lord have no sorrow
added to them that's right he said that
in the Psalms and if you have sorrow
added to something it's not from God
and this lady has sorrow they're about
to have their cars repoed and she's
thinking about divorce and she's
thinking about divorce because they're
going to pay their car payments so these
cars need to go in the meantime
you actually have eight thousand dollars
a month coming in
how almost 9 000 a month coming in how
do you not pay one thousand dollars
worth a car and two thousand dollars
worth of rent that's only three thousand
dollars five thousand dollars left over
after that how are you behind on those
because you didn't have them prioritized
that's what it tells me right okay after
30 years of doing this I have great
insight
[Laughter]
these are things that you need to build
into your your daily way of life your
budget is something that is not
something that you make once a year and
you come back to it when things are bad
you do your budget every single month
before the month begins you create that
plan you spend every dollar on paper or
digital paper every month before it
begins so you have a plan so you can see
what are the areas that need attention
maybe you do need to get your income up
that's not really the case in her
situation she's got a spin they've got a
spending problem and maybe you'll start
to see that as you put your budget
together but let's just pretend for a
second okay she said she's three car
payments or two car payments yes yeah
okay so what's it take to get current
and pay this month two thousand dollars
she could do that this month and what's
it take she's a one month behind on rent
yeah what's it take to get current on
that another 2 000 yeah it's four
thousand bucks yeah so you could be 100
current on the things that matter in one
month that's right and herself anything
else you're not gonna do anything else
something else might get behind what and
if something like if you got MasterCard
laying there they can jump in a creek we
get we we don't get evicted
and we don't pay MasterCard if we got to
choose when you like the taste of steak
at a restaurant more than you like the
feeling of paying your bills on time you
got a problem hello
you would rather sit whine and dine
yourself you would rather go on trips
that you can't afford than just have the
Peace of paying your your bills on time
and sleeping at night yeah but here's
the thing if you're behind like that you
said it early in the conversation how do
you you're doing the budget wrong what
you need to do is you need to spend this
month's eight thousand six hundred
dollars on this month's problems and
until you clear food utilities housing
and transportation and get them all
current you don't spend anything else on
anything I don't care if somebody
doesn't like it oh and you stop your
stupid 401K withholding you're over here
making Investments while you're paying a
thousand dollars in car payments okay so
that this is what's going on in that
house yeah and not fussing at her I'm
just saying mathematically this is so
easy for some of you to turn around
within one month or two months you could
be a hundred percent current and on the
things that matter yeah because here's
the thing you emotionally
Dr John deloney could do a whole clinic
on this you're emotionally completely
shut down in crisis mode trauma mode
your brain your fit your critical
thinking skills shut down when you are
in threat of being hungry homeless and
have your lights cut off and your car's
repoed
these are the necessities of life yeah
to have you know food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities clothing we
don't need to worry about you know you
got clothing okay shut up there's 73
pairs of shoes in there shut up you
don't need clothing
good Lord the money we spent I mean
we've got enough clothing last okay yeah
so um I mean if you're trying to make a
fashion statement you're getting evicted
you've got other issues right well you
got to grow up Dave and I can say I can
say that because I've been there I've
had to look in the mirror and go Jade
you're acting like a child you're buying
clothes you're going out to eat and you
cannot pay your bills you've got to
change you've got to do what you're
doing differently doing things the same
way and expecting the same result that's
Insanity so and I was an insane child
take care of the four walls first that's
not Insanity it's the opposite food
shelter clothing transportation and
utilities get current on them before you
worry about anything else everyone else
can jump on the creek until that's done